what up friends woke up super grateful
today it's a beautiful day beautiful
monday first day
grandma and tyka are watching despicable
me and just bonding look at them
they're having a good old time i just
finished training had a really good
sweat session to start the week off
right
he's over here dying
[Music]
i think he has like a set or two left
while he does that and before all my
meetings start this morning
i'm cooking up
some
lunch that will eat
hopefully for a couple days
one of the things i hate doing when i
diet
is thinking about what i need to eat
especially during the week i want it to
be thoughtless because i just already
have so many other things on my mind
that food is one of the last things i
want to think about so i want to set
myself up for success and
to reach all my fitness goals i love
the sounds behind me
so before you've been thinking about it
going i'm lazy i don't have time blah
blah blah i'd rather just knock it out
get it out of the way so when i come
down after all my meetings today at
around maybe one or two
um
even closer to three i can just come
down
and
eat
i don't know what i'm gonna make just
yet i've already packed a lot of our
spices and stuff this is all i have left
to work with
so out of that pile i gathered this
and see
what it'll taste like there's a lot of
cajun going on i think i want a lot of
flavor
going with the extra lean
beef i think it's 94 6. oh yeah 96.4
even better
wait where is it
okay whatever you get the idea i'm sure
you believe me
but yeah let's set ourselves up for
success
as early in the day or in the week or in
the month or in the year as possible
please let me help you stay on course
let's get this
not too sure what i'm making but so far
i don't hate the way it looks
no clue
you put garlic obviously yep just all
this stuff smells good what else just
whatever's here you put chives yeah
garlic salt yep what is this oh i didn't
add this guy because it's too much cajun
seasoning smells good yeah we'll see
what happens i'm gonna throw in some
peas i'm just trying to get rid of a lot
of ingredients thank you that's awesome
smelling and tasting
you're a [ __ ] cartoon character
i can't believe it you are straight up
cartoon
right
dude
that's a beautiful scene over there i
know that's how cute isn't it
okay finished with work and now it's
time
to continue
packing look at this
i bought a lot of supplies from um this
place this place called uline
they sell all industrial like um
machinery not machinery but like
equipment that you need
if you own a business like warehouse
things like warehouse type stuff like
anything that costco uses to store their
goods
like pellets anything displays stuff
like that go there they have it at a
discount um but yeah i bought all my
packing stuff there because i'm like i'm
not about to go to home depot and spend
extra
and uline has way more stuff they ship a
lot faster
um so i don't even have to leave my
house and when we get movers they charge
you for every single thing that they use
so every little box that they use to
pack up your stuff has a cost to it
right which is fine and i think it's
fair but
they charge you a premium because they
know that you need the box and again
it's fine because they picked it they
sourced it like they're the middleman so
they need to be making cut from this i
get it so i'm not mad at that um but if
you want to avoid all that stuff
especially if you're going to be packing
it yourself go through uline you like
can you sponsor me like yo i just gave
you this fat ass plug but really uline
is pretty is is pretty the [ __ ] not
shitty but pretty the [ __ ] yeah
so like a bunch of our my shoe boxes i
put it in one two three four five six
seven eight see that so they could just
pick it up
take it put it in storage
it's been so hot these days that i'm
like i hope my shoes don't melt
just kidding they shouldn't melt
obviously
watch them melt
my helper is having way too much fun
packing hey monkey can i ask you a
question
how come you're in your underwear all of
a sudden cause i like my hands are so
funny why do you think it's funny
because before you always wanted to be
in your
pajamas yeah
and now you want to be in your underwear
[Applause]
okay you're fired sir
eight
hey monkey you wanna do something fun
yeah we're gonna drop the tissue up here
yep okay but you wanna move that blanket
because you're gonna slip
no you're gonna slip put it give it to
grandma how about under here sure
okay i'm gonna go upstairs
and i could
technically
bring it all down myself right
but how boring is that
so boring so what i'm going to do
is
throw down
some
toilet paper
this is all the stuff we're bringing
to our temporary home so anything that's
light let me just throw it down there
have them have fun
a little bit okay
here we go
ready
all right ready
here we go
yay
you got it
okay put it on the table
no no no on the table
the floors
the big table that you're standing next
to dude
yeah i don't know what do you call that
oh is it still a table
okay you ready for the next one
here we go
oh
so close
yeah do another one
you're not ready
okay ready
here we go buddy
you're good dude
you're good
let's hold it like that
[Music]
okay
no no just one
go behind that couch over there
okay ready
you ready
okay
i'll do another one
okay what about this
okay ready
yeah i got a little scared no no no no
go put on the table
[Music]
oh and it's loose okay
what did you say i caught you on camera
what did you just say
for you
what did you tell papa
so what happened show me again for a
plate and i squeeze the steam buns and
as soon as i squeeze my steamboats see
right
oh you're not missing buttons
come here let's show that
it's cute
[Laughter]
all
and then tell them okay ready the camera
okay
hey what did you tell papa
hey what did you tell papa grandma you
want a piece of me or what did you say
do you wanna make me see my name no not
that one do you want a piece of me that
one
okay what's the other one was it
[Music]
you have really good sayings dude you're
so funny okay what's going on over here
you guys have been playing on this couch
for quite some time
[Music]
and like in the middle of camping the
dentist came and was checking on my
teeth
whoa
hey you're on top of the tent
hey so were you papa's dentist yeah he
didn't have any cavities how many
cavities did he have 50 000.
what how many teeth does he have 50 000.
oh very good answer hey where'd your
body go
hey there's a boy without a body oh
there it is let me get underneath all
the way
it's a cool tent huh i'm not gonna shoot
something like it's gonna come out let's
see
what's going on there what's going on
hey inside inside he only has stinky
stuff too
and even that smells good we threw it
out of here
only stinky stuff
the only one stinky stuff in there yeah
hey palazzo's a stinky guy for sure we
only have three stinky things in
there the hospital what are you doing in
the hospital now
the story is
like you know what i did what'd you do
[Music]
you guys are cut from the same cloth
what happened
oh no
[Music]
it's his fruit punch
but he said he's bleeding
so what did you just say you trash
monkeys
i don't know how to do women's work here
i'm gonna leave it right here you
you better do it do it right now do it
right now
so what do i do i'm gonna smack you what
do i do well you're lying because you
walk to the kitchen i use this and i
just
like this
oh i know i did like this
it's gonna stain dude i'm gonna do the
woman's work
they're not gonna need to wash it
i can't believe it
is there anywhere else on the couch
uh on the rug maybe
on the rug
it's okay well we're going to leave it
damn you really don't know how to do
this woman's work huh no i really don't
try not to be a woman
these feet
he's gonna fart in your face
that's disgusting
that is so disgusting
go wash your mouth you're going to get
ringworm now
yes go wash it
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding monkey
no you won't but please don't do that
again okay that's disgusting
don't do that anymore because you could
really get bacteria okay
so i put on his underwire
that's disgusting okay yeah good yeah
wipe your mouth because you know what
happens in the boat right what
poo poo
hey
i'm waiting on you
dude
okay cut it out
[Laughter]
you're so funny
he knows it makes me uncomfortable so i
can't show him
any of these things because then he's
just gonna go for it and he's gonna try
to do everything to make me
uncomfortable is he following me with
his butt
and please stop dude you're making me
uncomfortable
[Music]
should i put it in the washer
look at that see that took this
like this
you want to
oh no you broke his leg strong guy
oh no that's coming the stinker
the stinker oh no the other sticker's
coming two stinkers
he's gonna swallow you
no
that's disgusting stop
he put his face in your butt
that's disgusting please stop
[Applause]
[Music]
stop
these are a funny pair
hey
[Music]
all right these weirdos are gonna go
take a shower take a shower take a
shower see you later monkey oh my god oh
my god oh my god
goodnight
baby you burped goodnight i love you
oh my god okay all right
all right guys thank you so much for
spending your time with me um i really
do hope that the last few minutes of
this vlog made you laugh and smile
because
this boy is
the [ __ ] best and i'm so happy i get
to share them with you so enjoy
and we'll see you tomorrow